la vie à la campagne est extrêmement
difficile
l'emploi est presque inexistant le
survie des femmes ainsi que celle de
leur famille dépend de la production et
de la vente des produits agricoles
certaines d'entre elles marchent
plusieurs heures
traversant des rivières pour arriver aux
marchés publics ses ago commerçantes
sont nombreuses elles sont partout
quant à antoine est cette mère
célibataire de deux enfants pour qui
elle rêve les yeux ouverts
en les voyant déjà médecins et avocats
elle ne rate aucune occasion de leur
apprendre l'importance de l'éducation du
civisme et du respect de l'environnement
antoinette est une madame sarah nom
donné aux commerçantes à l'instar d'un
petit oiseau migrateur d'haïti
les madame sarah sont des femmes qui
laissent leur ville natale pour se
rendre à port au prince afin de liquider
leurs marchandises je suis trajet se
fait le jour comme la nuit
chaque vendredi
antoinette se rend à la station pour
installer ses marchandises dans le
camion
un camion très souvent surchargées dans
lequel les madame sarah et les
marchandises sont entassés comme des
sardines le jour comme la nuit
ces dames elles sont exposées au soleil
au vent à la poussière et à l'appui les
deux fils d'antoine est jacob et franck
adore faire le trajet avec leur maman
sans savoir que leur vie est en danger à
chaque fois tous les jours ces dames
sont confrontés à des difficultés sans
pareil elles sont délaissés par les
autorités locales
voler violer assassiné par les bandits
abandonné ignoré par la société civile
et pourtant elles font vivre des franges
entières de la population
antoinette n'a pourtant pas reçu
d'éducation scolaire mais elle est d'une
grande intelligence et d'une saga cité
extraordinaire en plus des rêves qu'elle
a pour ses enfants elle en a aussi pour
ses collègues ce lieu qu'elle fréquente
ce travail qui a sur sa vie elle veut
protéger cet espace le sécuriser dommage
antoinette n'a pas le support de ses
pairs puisqu'elles sont déjà trop
habitués à ces conditions infrahumaines
les femmes haïtiennes joue un rôle de
levier de l'agriculture le développement
de ce secteur est lié à une organisation
de leur activité par l' approche
entrepreneuriale l'entreprenariat
féminin est en effet l'une des meilleurs
moyens de valoriser le statut
socioéconomique des madame sarah
décembre c'est le mois des affaires le
mois des profits le mois de la chance le
mois au toutes ces dames profite pour
avoir du bénéfice pour vendre beaucoup
plus paradoxalement c'est le mois des
accidents un week-end du mois de
décembre 2015
c'était le dixième accident ce genre là
plus de quinze mois une vingtaine de
blessés
antoinette a péri dans cet accident
un cauchemar pour ces enfants qui se
sont retrouvés seuls
seul dans cette grande ville de port au
prince
seul avec d'autres enfants de la même
histoire du même destin tragique
cet accident n'a pas seulement apporté
des vies mais aussi et surtout des rêves
des projets d espoir
le rêve d'antoinette est à le changer la
situation des madame sarah elle voulait
secouer leur conscience secoué la
conscience de toute la société
exiger des actions des autorités elle
avait une vision même si antoinette n'a
pas vu la concrétisation de ses rêves
d'autres agences ont voulu poursuivre
son idéal par l'âge par la création
d'une chambre de commerce des femmes où
toutes les femmes quel que soit son
niveau d'éducation
quel que soit son niveau d'ambition et
d'initiative toutes les femmes qui
entreprennent
ils sont admises
le but principal de cette chambre est de
promouvoir l'entrepreneuriat féminin par
la participation active valorisé et
reconnu des femmes dans la vie
économique
elle entend aussi faciliter la mise en
commun des ressources des compétences
pour augmenter maximiser le profit de
ces dames
le des projets imminents de la chambre
et la proposition de système de
transport pour les madame sarah ce qui
leur permettra de voyager dans les
meilleures conditions et de réduire le
nombre d'accidents la chambre entend
organiser et de ces femmes les
accompagner techniquement pour mieux
gérer leurs affaires
aujourd'hui partout
toutes les sociétés nous présente des
situations exceptionnelles des
situations qui interpelle notre action
qui interpelle notre implication qui
interpelle notre conscience des
situations exceptionnelles qui
interpelle l'action citoyenne je vous
invite à agir
agissez avec le peu que vous avez agi
c'est maintenant fait la différence même
si personne ne vous regardent fait
quelque chose
car si nous n'agissons pas aujourd'hui
si nous n'agissons pas maintenant nous
serons considérés comme les vrais
assassins de demain la mort d'une femme
c'est la mort de l'humanité est ainsi